my design team worked all night to bring
the hotel into the 21st century now it's
time to reveal then you came with your
tail to the staff good morning good
morning John hey Fillie I can't wait to
see what you've done in there right you
ready to go in the only way we're
getting in is with this okey let's go
let's go
the door is locked so your guests can
sleep safe and sound right come upstairs
I'm hoping you're gonna love my room I
think it's absolutely gorgeous
[Music]
taking the carpet out and putting that
flooring in absolutely transformed it
the wallpaper was expensive in order to
enhance a we work with it so we got the
back drapes above the vet we have this
amazing new floor perfect furniture that
fits the room which upgraded every room
with brand-new linen and towels $75,000
worth of linen oh my god oh my god we
could have never afforded that and it's
so wonderful I feel like kind of like a
kid that comes down Christmas morning
and there's so many things under the
tree that you're in overload I can't
really comprehend everything yet I mean
I'm just kind of looking at ring Wow
ready for more room oh my god I could
take it wow wow wow I can't wait to
actually show a guest upstairs to a room
I love it
it's been a challenging week at the
Keating Hotel a place that was all style
and no substance but its own eddie has
finally turned a corner good morning
it's time to show him and his staff how
my design team have transformed the
keating into a place people will
actually want to stay okay guys let's be
honest the Keating is a hotel with huge
potential right yes but you need to
focus your attention and energy to the
guests that are staying here yeah come
with me let me show you the Keating
let's go come in welcome oh my god
opened up Wow
there's no more dominant read read
carefully all those wonderful
configurations of your hands
welcome to the KT it's just an emotional
experience you all have a hand in
helping the guests feel welcome it's
amazing
you disappointed the red is gone no no
no it's a brand new warm inviting
entrance to hotel my design team worked
through the night to transform Milford
Pennsylvania's River Rock Inn and now
it's time to reveal the changes to Ken
and his team why how are we good how you
feeling great great excellent all of you
this week have really put so much effort
in to get this in back on track so I'm
greatly appreciative for your efforts
it's only fitting that we star the
relaunch with a proper sign take a look
at this
it's not the old side from the old
restaurant
it's a beautiful sign Rimrock inn and
restaurant the best food and lodging and
the Perkins how cool is that it's very
cool
does it rise beautiful it's wonderful
thank you okay ready to go inside yeah
excited let's go
come through are you ready it's a
beautiful place to live and stay not a
place you got to come and die
first off we have a stunning color on
the walls Don is that hideous paper so
now it's in keeping with a rustic charm
and all the bugs are gone too
the changes are just incredible I'm a
bit overwhelmed by them I'm blown away
totally blown away